how do you define story
a story transports me to a different
place to a different world to
um a world and a life and meeting new
characters that immerse me in an
entirely new experience you know I think
about some of the early storytellers in
my life like my grandmother who was a
oral Storyteller and she would tell us
stories uh when we were kids about her
life and
um you know how she met her husband
stories of our youth when we were
children so I like to think of story as
you know there are stories that are
nostalgic with a beginning middle and an
end but when I think about stories in
general they're really a really great
format medium
no matter what kind of medium it is a
place to be transported into a world and
characters that you might not know it's
a it's a way for you to
um
walk in someone else's shoes to have
empathy for another character and to see
someone else's life through their eyes
uh I I think that that's extremely
important for us as human beings and
living in the society that we live in
today to be able to hear other people's
stories through their own voices through
their unique perspectives
to really
appreciate understand empathize with
how they see the world
um so I don't know that's a roundabout
answer but uh
story transports you
what is immersive storytelling
immersive storytelling there's many
various definitions for this but in my
mind it's using tools and techniques to
immerse a guest a participant an
audience member into an immersive world
where they use all of their senses in
order to immerse themselves in a
particular world or story
and you know uh when I think about
immersive storytelling some of the most
successful ones out there
they are the ones that really think
about not just the visual or the
um
you know uh audio storytelling but in
what you touch and taste and feel
um and
and really have that interaction between
different perhaps different people or
different elements or objects that maybe
you can pick up that you can you know
explore and discover and to really feel
like you're immersed in a world or an
environment that you may not necessarily
be familiar with but you have that
suspension of disbelief to
allow the Storyteller the Creator to
take you there to really immerse you in
that uh place to play to have permission
to engage and immerse yourself in
something that you wouldn't normally in
your regular lives so to be immersed in
that story and feeling like
you're a part of it feeling like that
you're an important part of it is
extremely important I think too
um that you're not just a spectator that
you are an Engaged active participant in
that story so there are different kinds
of immersive storytelling ones where you
do come into a space an extremely Visual
and there's music and all of that but
you walk around like you're perhaps a
ghost or you don't have any effect
to the environment but then there's the
more extreme types of immersive
storytelling where you are an active
participant you can be a hero to that
story and you can really take part in
shaping the outcome of that story too so
there's different levels of
participation levels of Engagement of
what you can do in an immersive
storytelling world
does every place have a story
I think so I believe that every place
has a story
this room that we're in has a story uh
this house this town this city
it's a question of who's telling the
story right
um I think that if you asked the person
who lived in this house 50 years ago
versus 100 years ago
versus a thousand years ago right
um everyone has a different story to
tell
but yes 100 every place has a story and
every person has a story too and uh I I
find that one of the most fascinating
things to think about is
you know if you have that chance to tell
the story of yourself or the place that
you're in
what's the story that you want to share
with the world
Margaret what's your reaction to someone
saying entering a story is not just an
escape I think that it's
story is
um it is definitely a way for us to
understand and make sense of the world
around us it's a way for us as children
when we first heard stories and to
understand how
um what's right and wrong the you know
the good guys the bad guys the heroes
the villains all of these things you
know what's acceptable what's not
um what's the what's the right choice to
make what's not I think that for anyone
who hears or tells a story they come
they tell that story through their
personal and unique perspective and what
you pass down from generation to
generation is what you hope
will live on in terms of how you make
sense of the world and also how you're
not alone when you hear a story you
realize that there's someone else
whether you're reading a book watching a
movie experiencing a world you realize
there's someone else in the world who
understands exactly how I feel
and how I live my life and you know how
I what I dream of and what I hope to do
and what I hope to be one day because a
lot of the stories that we hear or
experience
the ones that really really get into our
hearts and our souls are perhaps
a way to fulfill a deep-seated desire
and a wish that's something we always
think about when we you know create any
type of stories what is what is the
audience's wish fulfillment what's their
fantasy and let's really get into the
heart of what people not only want and
desire but what they need and what
they're lacking in their lives so
telling a story does create that
understanding and that you know making
sense of the world and you know finding
the the commonalities between us and
that's something that is really exciting
to me like some of the best stories
um I've heard or read or experienced
may not have anything to do with a you
know a person that I'm you know or a
culture or a race or a lifestyle or
occupation that I'm familiar with but
because there's so many common Universal
truths to their story it touches us you
know it makes us understand it makes us
really connect with someone that could
be from you know living in the other
side of the world but you know as a
woman as a mother as a sister as a
daughter as a human being
being able to feel that and understand
that and make sense of that that's
really magical to have that story really
be felt
um
with every person that experiences that
story that's really that's really the
the goal of every Storyteller isn't it
to be able to touch
everyone's lives in a way that's very
meaningful
how is immersive storytelling different
from novel writing or screenwriting yeah
um immersive storytelling is extremely
different uh from
more traditional forms of Storytelling
like novels and screenwriting I think
because the role of the writer the
Storyteller is really part of a greater
team this is some this is not a solitary
Craft
um and you know I love to read books and
I love to watch movies and it's similar
with Film Production too I I'm I would
hope that you know the writer works with
a director and with the actors and all
of this but I think the role of the
writer and the Storyteller in immersive
storytelling is extremely
um important in that they are the story
champion and the guardian of that story
craft throughout the you know from the
beginning of the project to the end
because you have to find ways to be able
to embrace and celebrate that story in
various disciplines
um you know you talk to the landscape
designer to the architect to to the
audio engineer to the to the graphic
designer in terms of being able to tell
one story one story world let's say and
it's not experienced in just one medium
there might be some media components in
an immersive story World there might be
some um you know graphic uh elements
that you're reading
and listening to but as a whole it's a
very holistic type of Storytelling
because you are immersing all of your
audience members senses so that every
single detail of the first moment uh a
guest an audience member walks into your
experience until the moment they walk
out every single detail every single
thing they touch and feel and hear and
taste is all a part of that greater
story so how do you tell
a story or share a story or have your
audience member partake in that story in
such a way where they feel like they're
the hero and the active and an active
important part of that story and that's
very different from you know
um reading a novel or watching a movie
where the reader or the audience member
does not take part they're they're
viewers or observers or readers they
don't have a place in the story whereas
an immersive storytelling the audience
member the guest is a part of that story
and they are immersed in this world
where perhaps they can take action and
you know do and see it and
um
take action to have consequences in
terms of how the story plays out
so they become one of the characters to
the story and that's really a big
difference uh to any other
formats of Storytelling
how do people respond when you explain
that your job is to create an immersive
story that you're an immersive
storytelling
they usually question it they're
a lot of them ask what is an immersive
Storyteller why do you need a writer to
write immersive stories
uh what do you do exactly I think a lot
of people wonder and question but
they're usually very fascinated with
what that means and I think that you
know it's it's definitely a growing ever
evolving industry and craft so there's
never there will never be and I hope
they there never will be a definition to
describe what this immersive Storyteller
and writer does in this in any project
because it should evolve
um I don't think there should be one
format or medium to be able to tell an
immersive a really great immersive story
uh I think that the creators who really
push in terms of like how you would
share an immersive story with the world
um thinking about how they can just
break the barriers and really think
about how you can tell a story without
characters that you meet you know Lives
actors how can you tell a story in an
environment where there isn't anyone in
the room
um that's what we do a lot when we
design attractions for theme parks is
when you think about the queue you don't
meet anyone but yet you get a strong
sense of place you get a strong sense of
the character who may inhabit this place
or previously inhabited the place or the
person you're about to meet right you
get a you get this very strong sense of
place making is what we call it in the
industry so there's people often
question that and you know I start off
by saying well my experience and my what
I studied in film school was to be a
writer and screenwriter and I kind of
build it up from there so you know I
write for
um Theme Park attractions and rides and
shows and Museum experiences and really
trying to make this very uh holistic
type of Storytelling world where you can
experience a story and a place in and
very unique and one-of-a-kind ways
and at the end of the at for every
project you know our goal is always to
surprise and Delight guests and audience
members and visitors so that they can
see the world differently to think about
um you know new ways and new approaches
to living their own lives based on what
they've just experienced to really hold
a mirror to yourself and to reflect on
what you've experienced and to reflect
on how you can change your life for the
better how you can really bring you know
positivity and unity to your own life
and to the world
what is suspension of disbelief it's a
way for you as a Storyteller to really
immerse someone make them believe that
they are in that world in that space
and
it's a it's a storytelling
um
I guess way of explaining how you can
really immerse someone in an environment
and in a situation where they forget
everything else and they can be truly
present in
um in the world that you've created in
the story that you've created so being
able to suspend your audience's
disbelief in creating
um you know if you're walking into a
space that's supposed to look like
you're going into a space shuttle for
example can you suspend your audience's
disbelief that for a moment they truly
are and for a lot of the times when an
audience or a visitor goes into an
experience like this they are willingly
um
they willingly want to suspend their
disbelief because they want to
experience something that really
transports them into this other world so
uh as a Creator and as a Storyteller how
can you best
um
have that environment have that world
truly capture their imagination and meet
and exceed their expectations of what
being in a space shuttle would really
feel like right and how can you do that
with not only the environment that you
create but maybe through movement
through murmur through sound through
scent uh through what they feel and
touch and hear and you know
um
experience I think that that's something
as an immersive Storyteller you need to
think about is how do you suspend your
audience's disbelief so that they feel
like this is truly where they're walking
into and this is truly the world that in
their wildest imaginations has come
alive and come true for them
tools can you use to get someone to
suspend their disbelief
I think you can use whatever tool is at
your disposal I mean
I remember as a kid
going through the Haunted Mansion for
the first time in Disneyland and wanting
to recreate my own Haunted Mansion in my
own my cousin's actually bedroom
and
you work with whatever you can get I
mean whatever is around you you don't
have to have a multi-million dollar
budget you can work with
um whatever it is you have at your
disposal at the time you know it was
just moving around Furniture using
makeup to make ourselves look like
ghosts darkening the rooms having the
right music and a lot of
what you do to suspend an audience's
disbelief is your
allowing yourself giving yourself that
permission to really open up your
imagination and create something unlike
anything you've seen before and I think
the ones that are truly
uh game changing in terms of using Tools
in unexpected ways or using
um you know a different kind of medium
to be able to
suspend your audience's disbelief doing
it in a surprising way those are the
ones that really
speak to me those are the ones that
really uh surprise and Delight me
because it's not like you see you're
inspired by something and then
replicated in the exact same way because
there's plenty of that going on around
in the world right how can you create
something that has your mark your
personality your perspective your tone
um in a way that
reshapes retells that world that story
in a way that's unique and the way that
is authentically you so whether you're
you all you have is a basement or a
storage unit or uh you know if you do
have a whole mansion to play with you
know I think it really it's up to you as
the Artist as the Creator as a
Storyteller to really uh think outside
the box uh to think about how to use any
tool at your disposable at your disposal
to really create something truly unique
when you talk about in your book that um
when you read or watch a movie or even
hike that you're present finally because
especially today we're so distracted and
you talked about the urge to check your
phone even when you go in an elevator we
all do that but that you're truly
present when you're in a story that that
or even just in an environment whether
it's hiking or wherever so maybe that's
the real test is how present is the
audience and how can yes we make them be
present so that they don't have an urge
to to pick up the phone or something
else oh yeah definitely I think that
and the real test is when you see real
emotions right when you see you know
nothing gets me more than seeing you
know
kids kind of like their eyes widen
um because and children are really one
of the best I I feel like the the most
satisfying audience members for me
because when you could see it in their
eyes that they believe what they're
seeing
that is Magic you know being able to you
as a Creator Storyteller magician to
conjure up a world in which they believe
they're in it and that they're living it
is something that all immersive story
tellers should really strive for
um to really suspend that disbelief and
and have them be present and have them
forget about everything else especially
with kids who are
very screen
um you know they would rather the screen
among other things you know these days
and my nine-year-old son being one of
them
um we want to create that those worlds
and environments and places for them to
play again and you know there's nothing
wrong with playing video I grew up
playing video games I watched a ton of
TV and films but it's all about variety
and having that
um chance to really
forget about
um just the the daily routine and really
being present in a place where
it's not it's not just about what you do
every day and uh the things to check off
the list or anything like that it's
being able to let go giving permission
uh to yours for you to yourself to be
free to explore to discover to play to
engage to interact with people that you
wouldn't normally interact with to give
you the courage really to be in a story
and in a world where you might not
initially feel comfortable about but
really letting yourself go to enjoy it
and to participate I think that there's
so many things going on in the world
where you can just sit back and watch a
thing or be passive observers and as
immersive storytellers we really want
our we really want people to step in
and participate and to engage and to
interact and to act it's all these
active verbs that we always think about
when we create an immersive story world
and that's how even when we think about
a museum or a land or a ride or an
attraction or a show
sometimes all you know sometimes the way
that you can think about it is what are
the active verbs that you want people to
do is it to explore to
dive into a pool of sprinkles to go down
a slide to climb this ladder to you know
sit at a table where the plates come to
life
to speak with a stranger that's next to
you to open a door that opens to a
portal into another world right it's all
of these things that
you know you as a audience member
participant uh can have that opportunity
to do that's unlike anything that you
can do in your ordinary life and as a
Storyteller it's a really great
privilege
for you to have to create that
opportunity for other people to immerse
themselves in a world that that they
don't normally find themselves in
how does suspension of disbelief factor
into a great opening the great a great
opening is
um
extremely important in terms of
how quickly your visitor or audience
member
buys into the world that you're creating
and
as much as you know it really starts
from the very very first moment of how
you you know when you think about like
how you um walk down a path to get to
the experience or you know the door that
you open or the person that greets you I
think that every single detail and
element that leads you to the main
experience is something that helps to
create that suspension of disbelief and
you know in my book I talk about the
Walt's Haunted Mansion and how you think
about the fact that like the pavement
that you walk on the the graveyard that
you go through the wrought iron gate
um the cast members that greet you and
have that tone it's
immediately you get a sense that you're
no longer in the place that you were
just moments before in and I think that
being able to think about a story
in all of those elements not just
um telling a story verbally or a story
that's written to think about how you
create this immersive environment that
makes you believe you are in a different
place when you think about going to
travel to a different country for
example
the moment you get off a plane and go
through the airport and you know get
into a taxi whatever it is and arrive at
a place immediately you get a sense of
uh it's a different people different
culture a different language a different
way of doing things a different
different sounds different smells
different textures different temperature
every time I think about creating an
immersive story world I think about
traveling because that's one of my
greatest passions in me in life is to
immerse myself in different countries
and different cultures and when you
think about how every time you do travel
to a new country or a completely
different place there is this sense of
excitement anticipation and adventure
and your visitor wants that 100
they paid for your experience you know
maybe it's free whatever but you know
they're committed to your experience for
that time period
and the better you can create that sense
of place and to create that
belief that they are truly walking into
this world and this environment that
you're creating and making it so
seamless and consistent so that the
pattern doesn't break because as humans
we are pattern recognizers so if you are
in a time period That's supposed to be
the 1800s and then you see some modern
technology on the wall it immediately
takes you out you know
immediately so how do you think about
every single detail and element
that takes and transports you
and your audience member into a place
that they are willingly
able to suspend their disbelief and
enter your world and willingly and
openly want to participate and play and
engage in it then you've done your job
well as a Storyteller
um and that's something you know a lot
of different mediums are really
exploring and really trying to find ways
in which to immerse audience members and
visitors in new and unique ways and you
know I have to say video games do it
very well you know from their Inception
until now just seeing it evolve and how
as a player you get to really immerse
yourself in that story World immediately
that's something that a lot of immersive
storytellers can really
think about when they think about
creating that world you know you think
about video games and how immediately
you are a character who has a role in
this world and you have agency and
whatever action you take has
consequences you you know whether you
turn left or right or follow this
character or not follow that character
and go somewhere else all of these
things have these multi-branching
stories and narratives that you as a
player can follow and that's something
that's very exciting in the immersive
storytelling world to explore and you
know a really great example is sleep no
more in New York City where you do have
this deconstructed Narrative of Macbeth
and you can follow these characters in
different rooms and you follow a
character in their storyline and you can
explore a room on your own you can meet
people there's this sense of mystery and
exploration and this discovery that
feels very very unique and I'm excited
to see more and more of that how can
people really push the boundaries of
what immersive storytelling is and how
can you really involve not only yourself
as a participant but the people around
you to create something that feels like
a shared narrative that together you're
experiencing and that you're connecting
on a deeper meaningful level with
complete strangers I think that's some
of the greatest magic that I see in
immersive storytelling is that you're
able to find
um that human connection that many times
in our own lives maybe we've lost
and you said two two words that stuck
out to me too mystery and Discovery and
I started to think about for myself why
I like certain stories and I think that
that's a huge component and you want to
talk about being present in something
yeah when our mind is going like that
right right and I think that you know as
humans
we want to make sense of the world
around us and that's why you know
Mysteries and you know crime stories
murder mysteries all of that
we want to go down that rabbit hole
because we want to understand you know
we want to find a reason for why people
do the things they do would I do the
same thing if I were in that same
situation like all of these what-ifs
right and
um what ifs and what really happened and
you know
what more can I discover what more can I
find if I follow that you know path like
that's why a story like Alice in
Wonderland right is so captive uh
captivating to us because it's really
following a character that's uh brave
enough to go on that adventure and for
us to follow along on that journey and
to really discover what it means when
you are brave when you are fearless when
you do meet strange characters in your
life all of these things I think like
there's an inner child in all of us that
has that Curiosity and that desire to
discover and explore the world around us
what are some great openings and
immersive storytelling
oh boy
when you talked about the greeting have
you been thinking about even walking
into a restaurant in some sense is like
there's a little bit of Storytelling but
you talk about greeters and and and just
taking you immediately into that world
and knowing that you've left one world
and going into another yeah you know
um just one experience that I have to
call out is called The Nest in Los
Angeles and they
unfortunately they're closing soon so I
think people have a few weeks to book it
before it um the production closes down
but it's an immersive uh world where you
know you you go into this building and
one of the first things they do is put
you into
um uh a really old rickety elevator
and you go up on this you know Journey
that very curious very mysterious and
you don't know what's really going on
you go up just you and one other person
goes up on this rickety elevator and
you're basically uh told in a letter
that you've inherited a storage unit and
so you go through the storage unit and
piece by piece you uncover the story of
This Woman's life she has recently
passed away and through a very clever
medium which is just old school cassette
tapes that you put into a cassette
player in each of the rooms there's uh
there's actual activities that you're
doing an action that you're taking uh to
discover This Woman's life and
everything from like uh you hear her
voice from childhood to when she's an
older woman I think they really cleverly
put that together these two former
imagineers who put this experience
together that was a really great opener
for me a really memorable one where you
really feel transported and you do
suspend your disbelief to really explore
this um
creepy in fact a creepy environment for
you to really uncover the story of This
Woman's life
that's fascinating so you said it's
closing down yeah in a few weeks within
a few weeks forever
um forever but they're probably going to
do other projects
um but for now it's
um they it was running for a few months
maybe I don't know don't no don't quote
me on it it was running for a few months
but
um there it was a really clever way to
tell a story in a very contained and
controlled environment and the only
thing that you're given is a tape
recorder and a flashlight and so you're
going into this very immersive
um
from you know a hallway of a storage
unit and at one point you're developing
um film you know to look at some Clues
to open a lock like all of these things
and you feel really emotionally invested
to find out
um really the story of what happened to
this uh woman who left behind the
storage unit for you that's fascinating
so you get this letter from like a
barrister or an attorney or whatever and
it says you're the you know beneficiary
of this estate yeah I think it was you
won you won the storage unit oh yeah
okay yeah okay interesting yeah so then
you and do you you've seen parts of her
life not just here yeah and it's all out
of order too so it's a non-linear
storytelling and um it's brilliant uh
yeah so they really did a great job in
putting that together and really
thinking about this is another way like
when you think about like you don't have
to have you know millions of dollars to
create an immersive story you you know
simply use what's around you to best
represent the the feeling that you want
in creating this place so
um yeah the nest really I I definitely
recommend that
in your new book you talk about the
story method and if I may it's a share
theme one of a kind reflect and yearn
and so the acronym is s-t-o-r-y what is
this and why is it important
I was really trying to find a way to
make it really easy for storytellers to
remember the five important things
um to consider when they're creating
their story
and the first one is
s for story why share this story with
the world why is extremely important in
trying to understand
why uh why tell the story why do people
need need to know it and hear it and
from your perspective as a Storyteller
you have to really understand that and
really know the answer to why you're
sharing the story with the world
T is theme
and for any good story there should be a
theme and this is really what your story
is about
um and when you think about you know
children's books and fables and fairy
tales some of your favorite ones you
might not know it but there is a theme a
recurring theme that occurs throughout
the story and sometimes it's a lesson a
cautionary tale
um it could be something that really
puts a perspective on your life or other
someone else's life but something that
you can reflect upon your own life but
what is what is the story really about
it's not just about the plot of this
happens to this character and this and
this happens in the end but the theme is
really what is this story about
um in the not in the sense of the plot
but in terms of the real meaning behind
it
the oh one of a kind is if you are going
to share the story with the world how is
it unique can you place a Twist upon it
can you set it in a different
environment can you have different
characters can you
tell that story in a different culture
in a different world in a different time
period so that it feels fresh again
because when you think about some of the
really popular stories you know the The
Shakespearean Romeo and Juliet like
there's all these different versions and
ways that you can tell that story so how
can you make it feel fresh and relevant
and unique and one of a kind that's
something that not only just in terms of
like putting a your own perspective or a
Twist on it but perhaps the medium that
you tell that story in can you make it
into uh you know an opera or you know a
a children's book or um you know
changing the tone can you make it into a
mystery rather than a drama all of the
all of these things to really make it
feel One of a Kind R in the story method
is reflect and that's really questioning
why you are the best person to tell that
story and it might not just be you as an
individual if it is your own personal
project yes that is the question that
you should ask but if you're in a team
or you're working for a company or a
client why are they why are the company
the client uh whoever you're working
with why are they the best people
to tell that story and so that
reflection is really holding a mirror up
on yourself the Storyteller the Creator
the one who's going to
um you know share the story with the
world you really have to understand why
you should be the voice for it and to
really and if you are the voice what is
this perspective the unique perspective
that you're sharing with the world
because once you understand that then it
will feel One of a Kind it will feel
authentic it will feel like it's coming
from a genuine Place rather than one
that is contrived or
um something that feels like it's been
done before or something that doesn't
feel like it's anything new or
interesting so what is that different
perspective that you can bring in as a
Storyteller and a Creator to make it
feel like
there was no one else in the world who
can tell that story better than you
why in the story method is uh yearn and
that's really about the audience wish
fulfillment and this is something that I
always go back to again and again is
that each one of us you know in our
lives has a deep desire and a fantasy
that we want to fulfill and for one
person it might be to fulfill the desire
of being in a world of vampires and uh
feeling like you are a creature of the
night another person might be having
this wish fulfillment of like what does
it feel like to be a world famous
musician you know what kind of a
lifestyle can I live by going into that
world some people want to step into a
Fantastical world like Star Wars or
Harry Potter
fictional worlds that are very uh really
expansive and large and you know what is
that wish fulfillment for your
particular audience member it's all
about understanding and respecting who
your audience is and what you can not
only you know about meeting their
expectations but about meeting that the
exceeding those expectations and really
fulfilling on that guest promise so when
you think about
creating an experience and you know
what to think about what your audience
member what your visitor should would
want to do in this place you always
think back to well what is their wish
fulfillment what is the thing that they
aspire to do what is it that they dream
of doing when they think about this
world and this place and that's a really
great place to start
we talked about earlier how you love to
see the element of surprise on the
children's faces I'm sure adult children
as well and it must be very exciting to
see you know the parents that it might
be there for equal reasons because they
want to attend yeah and their element of
surprise yeah because you know all of us
have that inner child within us and I
think that when we create these
immersive stories for children of all
ages to experience including adults and
the adults that never really grew up uh
you know you really have that when you
create that space to give them
permission to be children again to
really let loose and play and engage and
laugh and dance and do all the things
that you can't do in your normal life
adult life I think that we need more of
that we need more opportunities for
um people to really play again and to um
fulfill their childlike curiosity and to
have that feeling of being adventurous
again and to really expose yourselves to
Worlds and to people that are unfamiliar
to you I think that when we start living
a life where we're more closed in and
rather than expanding our mindset and
you know exploring the world and meeting
different people and experiencing what
their lives can be like that's something
that I hope to do in a lot of the
stories that I create and whenever I
experience someone else's story I feel
like I want to know more about the
people and the world
that you know that are that surround me
I feel like that's a way for us to
better understand each other
um to put ourselves in other people's
shoes to really think about
um the world through their eyes and
through their perspectives because only
then can we have compassion for each
other and empathy
um and only then can we really have
meaningful dialogue and conversation so
storytelling is a really great way for
people to um
you know connect with each other even
people that you've never met before from
the other side of the world right so
it's a way it's a bridge it's a bridge
from one person to another it's a it's a
way for you to be able to share
something that you
hit that doesn't cost anything really
when you tell a story to someone else
right it's a way that you can reveal a
bit of yourself
um and for them to understand who you
are and where you come from and what
your story is about all of these things
I think it's just
um a really great way for us to connect
more as as a society as a world
a well-told story should feel almost
like a roller coaster ride yeah I I
believe that I think that
a well-told story has ups and downs and
it has twists and turns and it surprises
and delights you and terrifies you
um I think that a really well told story
should have that variety of emotions uh
and I think that when you think about
some of your favorite movies and books
and experiences they really take you on
that Journey from beginning middle and
end they
take you on a journey where you truly
Let Yourself Go you are present you
suspend your disbelief and you trust
that the Storyteller and Creator is
going to take you on this magical
journey and it's not just about the
Thrills and the screams and the
excitement but it's about that
anticipation you think about a roller
coaster from the moment that you're
lining up to get on the vehicle itself
your heart is beating you're excited
talking to your family and your friends
um you're trying to you know you're so
pumped up and excited to go on this
adventure and even when you climb into
the vehicle and you have your safety on
you and everything
going off of that ramp and you know when
you start chugging up the track it's
you're not thinking about anything else
you know you're thinking about oh my
gosh I'm just gonna go on this really
fast ride and there's nothing I can do
I'm out of control right I have to trust
that this coaster is going to take me
back safely to where I started but for
those few moments you really let
yourself go and be present and just
enjoy the ride and I feel like
well told stories do that right you
trust that you're going to be taken to
some extraordinary place
to go on your hero's journey if you will
and really depart on this and embark on
this adventure where you have this
excitement and this anticipation
and you go on a thrilling you know
twists and turns and ups and downs and
all kinds of things that you don't have
control over and you're surprised by how
not only you know you survive in the end
that you had a great time but it's this
feeling of
I think this this this release of
control that is extremely perhaps very
exciting for a lot of people because
all your life
um for the most part you have to really
think about what you're doing and
planning and you know it's a checklist
of things to do and accomplish and all
of these things and sometimes it just
feels good to let someone else take
control for a little bit and take you on
this really great journey and that's why
I think a lot of people come back to
like theme parks and amusement parks and
everything because it's a way for you to
truly
um
you know let yourself play and Release
Yourself from all these inhibitions and
engage in something that feels
extraordinary that is not is out of the
ordinary life that you live and being
able to transport yourself to this
playful
um you know playground of sorts where
you can really go on an adventure is
something that
um a well-told story does
and the the beauty of it is it's not
thrill every minute there's there's
Peaks and valleys too and yeah and there
are a lot of Peaks and valleys and well
toast stories I mean you know well-toed
stories make you cry as much as you
laugh right
um they touch you they you know some
stories can be extremely tragic but uh
there's a glimmer of hope in the end
um so all of these emotions of positive
and negative emotions and neither you
know they're not good or bad they're
just the scale of emotions the spectrum
of emotions that we as human beings
experience
um and so when I think about
you know going on a roller coaster
um it's really you know a metaphor to
the the life of um you know the Journey
of a well-tooled story in which there
are these Peaks and valleys and there
are ups and downs and all of them are
okay you know it's okay to be sad it's
okay to cry it's okay to feel to feel
scared and terrified because that is The
Human Experience
um and I think that if you know you live
your life wanting to experience
uh the peak all the time
then you haven't truly lived you haven't
you know experienced all that life has
to offer for you and that's why really
great stories take you there and make
you really reflect on
um you know all the various emotions
that you can experience in your life and
how you can reflect upon it
um in your own life with it with your
own family and friends and how you can
experience this colorful spectrum that
is life
we're just a creative process begin for
an immersive story
the creative process begins with a lot
of research that's something that I
think everyone
should always do as a step one if you
are going to tell a story especially a
story that's not yours to own
um I think that really understanding
the subject matter talking to experts
and having
the appropriate
subject matter experts and advisors to
help you truly understand a topic and a
world is extremely important I think
that if you jump into the creative
process without understanding
the context the significance you know
what's important about that particular
story
is uh can be very problematic
so I always want to find
um multiple perspectives on a particular
subject matter or topic or World
whatever it is to truly understand
especially if it's non-fiction
especially if it's something
biographical especially if it's
historical or educational
even if it's not even if it's a
fictional world
you have to respect
uh the subject matter and the story so I
think that research is
um number one the first step that you
must take as a Storyteller to any
project that you work on
can you talk about the brainstorming
process
you know there's so many different ways
to brainstorm an idea but I think as a
creative process and as creatives and
creative collaborators it's a really
great way to all be together in a room
when you brainstorm an idea and it
depending on the scope of your project
and the kind of project that you have
you may bring in some different
disciplines to really think about your
world through their various skill set so
you might have an illustrator or an
architect or a writer or a creative
director or a landscape designer it
really depends on the subject matter
that you're working with but ultimately
you want to have all these various
Representatives if you will of all these
creative disciplines come together so
that you're able to create something
that is seamless and integrated because
you're using multiple senses to
experience an immersive story you want
to make sure that all of these voices
are present in the room at the table
cultural experts story uh you know
subject matter experts all of these
things it's a way for you to really
throw out all the ideas and brainstorm
all the good and bad ideas together so
that you can really understand
what's important about the story you
want to share with the world and hearing
it from all these different disciplines
and from different people and voices is
extremely important to make sure that
you have a very diverse and
representative
representation of a story that is truly
unique and authentic and on the flip
side though let's take an example of
like you know the the quote too many
cooks spoiled broth so if we have too
many people how does it dilute it I mean
when do you know I think I have a good
mix
you know that's a really uh it's a good
question and I think that a lot of times
um
we you want to it really depends on what
we're talking about because there are
certain instances where you feel like
you really want to focus on an idea or a
topic and really brainstorm from that
idea but sometimes I think that it's
good to start out it's good to start out
bigger in some sense and maybe you
narrow it down from there
um I think that it's important to have
uh important voices heard in the
beginning because that really shapes how
you create that story
throughout the life cycle of a project
and
it really gives you you know as the
Creator a Storyteller you want to at
least for me personally I want to hear
everyone's ideas and as the story
Champion as the person who's going to
create the story I want to make sure
that all the voices within that within
the team are heard first and foremost
and in a way my job is to be a curator
to decide which of these perspectives
are the ones that we really want to
focus on which are the ones that are
important but may not take the spotlight
in this particular point in time what
are the ones what are the ways that we
can tell a story that's not so
um you know uh overt I guess can we tell
stories in ways that are more
um contextual and more suggestive rather
than something that is very um obvious
so I know that seems very like
strange to think about because
surely like with all the voices in my
head it would be confusing or
distracting perhaps but I think it
depends but for me I really want to hear
it all it's kind of like a funnel if you
you know for lack of a better analogy I
want to hear it all I want to hear all
the different perspectives and from
there really be able to hone in and
focus on what's really important what
are the common themes what are the
common patterns what are the common
things people are saying that have a
unified a more unified
um approach to how we can tell that
story so ultimately once you know you
have all the voices heard and you hear
all the different perspectives you can
have smaller groups and breakout
sessions to consider okay now that we
have this greater idea this big idea
concept of what our project is about now
let's we can go into smaller groups of
like how do we tell that story in this
particular room how do we tell that
story in the dining experience how do we
tell that story in the retail experience
right
so in that sense you can have more
focused groups to think about it but
you know as a Storyteller you you kind
of have to do both you're a generalist
and you're also a specialist when it
comes time for it you really have to
think about how you can use all of these
different stories ideas perspectives in
a much bigger arching story uh story arc
and then find ways in which you can be
more defined and focused in different
elements of your entire experience so
there's different ways that you can do
that but I think that it really depends
on how much time you have you know uh
how much money you have frankly for the
project as well and really think about
how best to approach it and the most
efficient and uh effective way
what was your role in creating Star Wars
Galaxy's Edge I started out as a writer
for the
overall land and what we call the
Village at the time so all of the
various
um retail and dining and character
experiences and as we thought about
building a whole new planet
um one that we have never seen before in
the Star Wars Galaxy we worked really
closely with the lucasfilm and the
imaginary teams to really develop a
place that felt truly Star Wars that had
the DNA of what made Star Wars Star Wars
and so I became sort of this uh story
lead for lack of a better word to really
connect and tie all of the various rides
and attractions and experiences together
as a holistic place as a world that
spoke to each other and that didn't feel
like it was just Standalone ride here
you know a retail here a dining
experience here that felt disconnected
we really wanted to find a way where it
felt like everyone from the cast members
to the characters that you encounter to
The Travelers that come to this planet
they all have a place in the story and
they acknowledge each other so
everything from like the training of our
cast members the local batuans we call
them to The Travelers that come to this
planet we really developed a culture and
a language and Customs to make it feel
like it was a real place in the Star
Wars Galaxy and it was a really great
way for us to really push storytelling
in all kinds of different mediums from
you know audio storytelling to
um graphical to the props that we used
they were there were a lot of Easter
eggs from like the films and the TV
shows that for Star Wars fans when they
walk by it and see it they're like
recognize it you know we really wanted
everyone to feel like they belong in
this world no matter what your level of
fandom was we wanted everyone from
someone who knew nothing about Star Wars
to the really super fans of Star Wars to
really enjoy this place and to want to
come back again and again and again so
my role was really to work with an
incredible team of creatives and you
know all kinds of other uh everyone from
like the engineers to The Architects to
you know everyone to create this
wonderful space to make it feel like it
was a believable authentic planet in the
Star Wars Galaxy
can you tell us about the research that
you did for Star Wars Galaxy's Edge
I I feel like I got a PhD in Star Wars
and my time at uh Walt Disney
imagineering I it was such a privilege
working with the lucasfilm team they
were so open and collaborative from the
very beginning when we first had the
conversations of building an immersive
Star Wars themed land and I remember
um the one of the uh team members of the
lucasfilm story team had said you know
we haven't told all of the stories in
the Star Wars Universe we're curious to
hear what stories you'd like to tell and
that really opened the doors for us to
really think about how we can
collaborate with them to create a story
that feels like something one of a kind
something unique and something that
makes it feel welcoming to everyone
and having that experience of
researching I mean
in addition to re-watching you know all
of the films back to back reading all
the uh watching the Clone Wars series
The Rebels series
um the Animated Series comic books
graphic novels books I mean we all it
wasn't just me we all did our research
in terms of you know what can we draw
what characters do we love what what do
we love about Star Wars that we want to
bring into this land and it was really
starting from that you know wish
fulfillment of
um what is that bucket list of things
that
we as audience members and fans want to
do in a Star Wars World
um and it involved everything from we
want to meet a Droid to we want to hold
a lightsaber you know what we want to
build a lightsaber
um and we want to uh feel the force we
want to Pilot the Millennium Falcon like
we want to be in the hallways of uh uh
Destroyer like all of these things we as
a team came together and talked about
and got really excited about and it was
incredible and what a great honor and
privilege to work
in a universe that George Lucas created
that opened up our imaginations you know
all of our imaginations
um at a time when you know science
fiction and like you know that type of
Storytelling was not really something
that was popular and when uh the first
film Star Wars film came out it just
kind of blew everyone away and we wanted
to do that again when we wanted to build
this land this was going to be the first
time
that fans can walk into a land that was
one you know 360 degree experience
multi-sensory experience the first time
that Star Wars fans and new fans would
come in and step into a world that was
truly Star Wars and that's a really big
big privilege you know fans have waited
over 40 years to walk into a place like
this and we did not take that lightly
you know we did our research with
um you know uh lucasfilm and with all
kinds of experts to really get into the
heart of what would make this place
really compelling and you know did we
get everything right maybe not no but we
felt like this was a place that really
transported people to
uh you know and you know when I talk
about the the emotional ride of a roller
coaster I've seen people cry I've seen
people laugh and you know grab their
children running to a place and children
grabbing parents running to a place and
you know me taking my own family and
friends into it and seeing the Delight
in their faces and walking away from an
attraction or an experience and being
like wow you know that that's everything
to me to be able to be a part of
something like that was one of the
greatest honors and privileges of my
career
in creating an immersive story why do
you focus on audience before you focus
on the characters in the world
I think that when we think about
immersive storytelling we always go back
to the idea of
you know the the person the audience
member who's coming into committing
their time
and energy into the space how do we
create an experience for them that is
truly immersive
and in any other type of Storytelling it
is about another person's story it's
another character going on their own
Journey having this adventure
but an immersive storytelling the hero
the protagonist is your audience member
is your visitor they're the ones who
want to commit this time to going on a
journey that is
for them that is unique to them that's
personal to them perhaps
um and so when we think about creating
an immersive storytelling world or
experience it is a multi-dimensional
video game come to life
this player if you will is going into
this experience and into this world to
do something to experience something and
so we create a story and a narrative and
a world around them and they are the
um the first person perspective of
looking around
um you know a space an environment and a
world we see it through their eyes and
so you know when I think about
any type of experience that I build I
always think that I am guest zero you
know I I want to uh create a world and a
story where I am
the visitor that is experiencing this
for the first time and how do I really
put myself in their shoes and see things
through their eyes and experience things
through the way that they would
experience it because when we have the
first guest the first visitor who comes
in they should
um be aligned with you know the
experience that
I and the team have created in order to
create something that is truly truly
compelling and engaging and we want to
surprise people and we want to make sure
that we engage with them
um in a way that really
opens up their minds you know shakes
them up or makes them think about and
see the world in a different way
um whatever your goal is in your
experience you really really have to
consider
what they're experiencing through their
eyes and through their perspective in
order to feel that this is an you know
an experience that is emotionally
engaging and meaningful and I think that
it's so important to think about it from
their perspective
because they are the hero of your story
they are the protagonist so how do you
create a journey and an adventure an
experience that is about them
um so it's a very very daunting task
because maybe one person's perspective
or
um experience of a place can be
different from another person who
experiences the same thing and that's
completely fine because no two human
beings are alike but how do you create a
world a story a place that really makes
them feel something that perhaps
transforms them because that's something
as storytellers and creators we want to
do is we want to transform people we
want to change them in a positive way in
in a way that opens up their minds
broaden their Horizons
allows them to explore and play and
engage and discover in ways that they
never thought they would you know maybe
there are even experiences that makes
them feel more like themselves
then they would normally feel in their
ordinary lives you know we hear about
people who
um you know have an avatar that's of a
different gender or plays a role that
they don't normally play in their real
lives and in perhaps in this experience
they can truly feel
more themselves than they've ever been
and so the the role of the Storyteller
so important
to be able to allow for that platform
that for that world to exist for people
to truly
feel like
um
they belong that they connect that they
can understand the world around them in
a way that feels very meaningful and
purposeful to them
how does the Storyteller know who Their
audience is
that's a really good question I think
that
sometimes you don't always know
um I think that if you are working on a
particular story
um that's you know popular knowledge or
you know of Pop Culture you know who
your fandom is your target audience is
but if you're working on a story for a
museum or a larger General audience I
think that
as much as possible you want to be
inclusive of everyone
um and I think that you really want to
um maybe research in terms of like the
market that you're in uh who's most
likely
um going to attend your experience but
also knowing your age group as well is
this an experience for children is this
an experience for teenagers is this an
experience for adults or for everyone
and it's extremely challenging to try to
please everyone but
you want to make sure depending on your
experience you want to make sure that it
is inclusive of everyone so that they
feel like they can belong in your story
World
um and if it isn't appropriate for a
younger audience or for a particular
group of people then that's something
that you need to communicate beforehand
you know that's something that you want
to make sure that your audience's
expectations of the experience is what
they think it is so I think that it
really depends on who you're trying to
reach out to and whether or not
um
that truly is your audience sometimes
can be surprising
um sometimes it doesn't necessarily you
know what you expect to be your you know
maybe your the majority of your audience
members might it might not turn out to
be that way and you're going to be more
appealing for the younger audience or
whoever it is right like I think that it
just it depends on your experience for
sure
and the audience will surprise you
sometimes you think they're going to
love one thing and it turns out they
actually hate it or they love something
that you never even considered yeah and
and a lot of the times in
you know in this industry you make
changes you adapt right if something
doesn't work out if something isn't you
know built to the expectation of the
audience how can you improve upon it and
how how can you change it how can you
make some amends so that it is something
that they were hoping to experience
something that is more compelling and I
think when you think about designing
your experience you want to keep in mind
that there could that you should be
flexible in that you should think about
um how if you needed to make a change
it's not going to be so time consuming
or costly to your project can you find
ways in which it can be classic and
Evergreen are there ways that it could
be a an easy way for you to switch out
you know a character or an element of a
story whatever it is so that it always
feels relevant and current
um and um you know something that is
always
that feels new to people so it really
yeah it really depends I think on um the
subject matter and also you know how you
what you're trying to accomplish in the
first place like really understanding
what the goal of that experience is and
um
yeah knowing who your audience is
who are streakers strollers and students
oh okay so this is a term that was
coined um a few decades ago by a museum
educator
and uh especially in the Museum Industry
there's the the streakers the strollers
the students are also sometimes called
the streakers the strollers the scholars
um Street if you think about going to a
museum the streakers are the ones who
just kind of want to walk through all of
the galleries all of the rooms and just
get a glimpse of everything
um quickly and the strollers are the
ones who you know they'll take time to
meander through all the galleries maybe
stop at a particular painting or a piece
of art and really enjoy it before they
move on to the next object
and the scholars or the students are the
ones who want to absorb everything about
that particular piece of work or every
single piece of work in the museum so as
a museum designer or an experienced
Creator you want to think about all of
those different levels of Engagement if
you will
and how do you create an experience that
is appealing to all of them
um there could be you know I see
examples in museums where they have like
just a short description or a title of a
painting and the artist and
um if you want to read further you can
there's more information and if you want
to dive even deeper maybe you'll listen
to a podcast or the audio tour or you go
on one of the tours with one of the
guides right so having that
different options for your visitors to
engage with whatever level that feels
comfortable to them that makes them feel
like they you know got their uh um but
their value for coming to visit your
experience is a really great way to
think about how you want to create
um an experience that will appeal to all
those levels of um participants and you
know there's other ways that people
think about it it's you know in a
fictional world it's levels of fandom
um and some people like to think about
it as like you know uh what's it's the
the waiters the swimmers and the divers
is also another way that people talk
about you know how deeply they want to
immerse themselves in a story a world or
a topic and so it's uh it's really good
to keep that in the back of your mind
when you're creating a place because if
it is uh an experience that's designed
for young children let's say then maybe
it is more about
um the very you know the the streakers
or the waiters right they just want to
get a sense of everything just a little
bit of here and there and they're not
going to be reading every single plaque
on the wall or anything like that
they're going to move on to the other
thing
but if you're creating an experience
that perhaps is historical or
biographical
um then you want to make sure that you
are being a hundred percent
um accurate and fair and responsible in
sharing that story with the world so
it's an extremely big responsibility as
a Creator and a Storyteller to think
about all those different levels of
Engagement and how they can participate
in your story and your world
can we talk about the six types of
audience roles okay the first one is a
visitor
yeah the visitor is when you what you
think of when you have an art gallery or
a museum
um where the visitor comes in and they
enjoy
um and appreciate works of art or
objects or um you know they come to
learn they come to
appreciate a place but they don't play a
role in the story of The Experience they
are visitors to the place where uh the
environment the story world is not
affected by their presence so this is
the most common uh type of uh experience
where people will go to a you know
everything from a playground to a museum
they're visiting a place and they don't
have an active role to play in the
experience this is passive yes okay and
then number two is a spectator that also
sounds passive yeah a spectator
um has is a more passive a participant
as well you could think of like sporting
events or concerts but there's a little
bit of participation in that they can
respond to the performer or to the
athlete that you know they can clap they
can scream they can shout their support
all of the or boo right so there's a
little bit more participation but it's
it's still somewhat passive it's not as
uh
um
participatory as other forms of visitors
number three is participant hyphen
immersive
when you think about some of the
immersive experiences out there
um where they have projection mapping
around a space and the um the the
environment reacts
towards the participant that goes into
this immersive space maybe you touch
something and you know there's like fish
in a digital fish in an aquarium let's
say and if you touch you can feed the
fish by like you know touching on the
wall or something like that so there is
a form of participation that requires
you to engage with the immersive
environment around you it doesn't change
the story in a drastic way but it
responds to you as you touch or
um perhaps whatever kind of action that
you do to create something that may have
uh
um a small consequence but nothing that
is going to change the outcome of the
entire experience or the story it's a
light touch light touch participation
participant Interactive
so uh participant interactive is
um
a little more engaging
um perhaps it's a crank that you have to
turn in order for this invention or this
machine to work maybe it's some buttons
that you have to push maybe it's uh you
know handles uh that you have to pull
and look through and discover so there's
a sense that it is interactive that you
are required to take some action in
order to fully experience uh the story
and the world and it's a great way for
kids to explore the world around them so
I love seeing museums and places where
kids can just touch everything and
interact with things so that they can
learn about it science museums is a
really great example of that and uh just
really engaging
actively participatory type of
activities
where you can really see uh you know
results and consequences is to your to
your actions
number five hero
so hero is one in which
if you go through this experience and
the story world
characters the experiences around you
have a direct consequence to your
actions so if you are going to meet with
a character in a town let's say in this
world
um whatever you say or do with this
particular
character is going to have very big
consequences to the world so this is
really the most extreme form of
immersive storytelling how can you as a
Creator put your visitor into a hero
role where they can change the
consequences of the story in the world
and again I go back to video games you
know gaming where you truly have this
opportunity to change the um you know
the true Choose Your Own Adventure type
of format where you can change the
outcome of your story and other
characters outcomes as well is the most
extreme form of immersion of
Storytelling that you can do and I think
we have yet to really see
um an experience where it fully does
that where you can truly create uh an
outcome that is personal extremely
personal to you it's difficult and
challenging because you have you know
Mass groups of people visitors audiences
coming to a place so how can you create
a story that's tailored only to you and
personalize only to you when you're in
this setting with crowds of people and
so there are different ways that you can
do it there's some that makes it a truly
personal experience or just you and one
other person if you think about like
some of the experiences out there in the
world when you're traveling let's say
and you have a private guide who takes
you to through a safari or whatever it
is right there's there's varying ways
for you to be the hero of that story in
that Journey but it's it's still one
that we're we've touched the surface of
an immersive storytelling and I think we
have a long way to go to really create
something that is truly
um that truly makes you feel like you
are the hero of the story and I'm really
excited to see where it can take us
and then Creator last but not least this
is one that I think gosh you know when I
think about
where immersive storytelling can go
and how I'm seeing the trends of what
you know my kid and the younger
Generations are doing in their own free
time things like Roblox and Minecraft
and fortnite where and you know being
YouTubers
there is a desire to create and express
yourself in uh your own way
how do we create an immersive
storytelling experience or world where
we can embrace you as a creator
and this is perhaps
touching on you know the metaverse or
touching on something that you know AR
or something that is more virtual
but is there a world where there is a
combination of like the physical the
digital the virtual where it feels like
perhaps There's No Boundaries anymore
right and it for a lot of people that
can be really scary to think about you
know what's real and what's not
um but when I see
what's what's emerging in this world and
how we all want to have that sense of
ownership and uh a sense of creation I
think that this is really going to be
what's going to be very exciting in this
particular format of immersive
storytelling how can you
create a world that is specific to you
and have visitors perhaps come to your
world experience the story that you set
up we see that in TV and movies and
video games
maybe we can see that in the physical
world maybe we can see that in a way
that is scalable uh you know that other
people from some other part of the world
can come and experience the world that
you've created and how do you create
something you know invite others to come
and co-create with you how do you create
environments that change with time that
evolve over time that perhaps does it
organically I know that it's something
that um I'm very excited to see because
it really pushes
how we think about how we perceive the
world and what is you know all my life
since I was a child I think there's
always been you know multiple worlds
that I live in in my head
and imagine if there is going to be a
landscape
where you can go in and out of those
worlds as you please that it doesn't
just live in your head
that it can be uh um
manifested into something that other
people can see and share
and that you can continually change and
evolve into uh an ecosystem that other
people can come in and collaborate as
well and again we're seeing it in video
games we're seeing in all of this but
how do we how can we bring that into the
physical world
what are emotional anchors immersive
storytelling emotional anchors are a
really great way for you to think about
how each experience of Your World should
feel
so if you think about if you're creating
a land let's say and you have an
overarching theme of what this land is
about
and like the emotional roller coaster
that I talk about what is it about each
of these places that makes you feel all
those different emotions so there might
be a particular experience that's about
um mystery that's about
um you know
having that sense of discovering
something mysterious and perhaps that is
the emotional anchor of that place is
it's mysterious it's capturing that
sense of you wanting to find out the
secrets of a place and what does that
look like how does that manifest into
something physical
it might be uh there might be another
area where it's all about
love and friendship and companionship
and what does that look like in your
world in your in your environment and
it's and what kind of love is is it what
kind of friendship is it so when you
think about all these different
emotional anchors in your land or in
your environment
um it's a really great way for you to
ensure that you have that spectrum of
emotions that is felt throughout uh your
entire story world and experience and
you know there might be some areas that
are um you know light touches of emotion
it could just be like a moment of humor
uh human uh a moment of like um
playfulness let's say and so those
emotional anchors are a way for your
audience members if you think about like
watching a movie or reading a book there
are moments where you laugh out loud
there are moments where you cry so
we're just laying that out in a physical
world right like what does that look
like and having those emotional anchors
there
um not knowing where your audience
member necessarily might go to first as
well but if you can ensure that everyone
does for the most part and go to all of
these emotional anchors and feel it then
they will have a more cohesive
experience to your world that you've set
up and to ensure that they go through
that whole emotional rollercoaster of
your of your experience
why do you compare emotional anchors to
plot points
like a good story
um in a movie or a book
there's plot points are usually
um the the moments in the story where
things something happens right something
big happens and it changes the course of
the hero's journey
um so when you think about emotional
anchors and depending on whether it's a
linear experience or a non-linear one
you have to think about them as plot
points as well they are those
significant moments in the story
where perhaps the course of the hero's
journey changes it it Alters based on
what they decide to do the action that
they take so if you're looking at your
visitor as the hero of the journey they
may decide to come to this particular
place the plot point where they
experience that particular emotional
anchor and then move on to the next
thing to the next thing because you want
to create this this journey of sorts
where we do have those Peaks and valleys
of the um the Arc of the experience for
that hero so in a way it I I uh compare
it to the more traditional form of
Storytelling in which we do have plot
points emotional anchors are a really
great way to think about
um
it as a plot point to your particular
experience
how do you create emotional anchors I
think it really depends really
understanding
um what it what emotion you're trying to
capture for your audience and really
um
understanding if it's you know how it's
crucial to the story of the experience
so it's it's hard to talk about it when
we're top not talking about something
that's specific a project or a story or
world but you really want to capture
that um emotion in your visitor in which
they can feel like they've progressed or
that they're learning something or
they're discovering something about
themselves or the world or another
character or the
plot or the story arc of the journey
it's about revealing layers to not only
the the hero themselves but as I
mentioned like to other characters or to
the world
and and each discovery
of these uh in each emotional anchors
it's a really great way to reveal
different sides of the story to make it
more complex to make it more layered so
if you have an experience that's just
one emotional beat and tone it feels
very flat you think about any song you
know or any musical score
there are no you know great songs out
there that's just one note right
um so how do you create that textured
that multi-layered uh narrative and
emotional beats where it does reveal
something else about the world or the
environment that is surprising and that
reveals an emotion that you didn't think
you would have about a particular
circumstance or a situation or even a
character right
um so it's a really great tool for you
to think about
how you can create something that is
very textural that feels very
um intentional in its design and how you
can layer in uh more
you know story lines story like or
feelings to a place rather than just the
one the one note of uh uh of an emotion
Margaret in World building what do you
mean by if you make it personal you will
make it Universal
I think it's so important to think about
how
you can make a story extremely personal
and
authentic to your voice for people to
understand it in a greater context
I made the mistake when I first started
out as a writer thinking that I would
write something that everyone would love
and
um you know looking at all the my
favorite movies and books and everything
and trying to find a story that is
pleasing to everyone
and
I I over the years I learned that it's
really when you dive deep into yourself
and trying to find the stories that
really make
you who you are in your own life and
drawing upon those experiences life
experiences to make it
feel genuine and personal in any story
that you work on later in life and so
when I work on anything I draw on that
personal experience because
anyone you know a visitor reader a
spectator can feel
that it's not authentic or Genuine if
it's something that's fabricated and the
more that you make it personal
I find that you know this is the whole
phrase of write what you know I didn't
understand that until later on in life
that now I understand that that's what
it means that you have to make it
personal in order for people to
understand and that it goes back to
uh you know what makes us human the
universal human truths that we all share
we all love hate we understand revenge
and envy and jealousy and all of these
things but we all experience it in
different worlds and contexts with
different people in our lives and you
know different situations but when you
make it personal and you draw on
something that is extremely felt in your
own way and you're able to express that
and manifest that into a story that is
extremely personal to you then I believe
it is universal to anyone who
experiences it
Margaret what's the three second rule
that you refer to in your new book
so the three second rule is if you're
creating a world or
um an immersive experience
if your audience member doesn't
understand the world they're in in three
seconds or less
then you have not successfully
um suspended their disbelief and this
idea came uh you know the first time I
heard it was a story about George Lucas
when he was creating his um the Star
Wars universe is that when an audience
member looks at a Star Wars world and if
it doesn't feel and he was creating it
you know if it doesn't feel like
something that belonged in the world he
was creating then it does not belong
um so it was a really interesting way to
look at the world that you're creating
to make sure that it's consistent
throughout
um your whole experience and if you're
creating something that is truly
immersive then it should feel immersive
from every to every single detail from
beginning to end and it should be it
should all speak uh you know in the same
you know it should feel like it belongs
in the same world World it should feel
like it isn't jarring or that it's out
of context or it breaks the pattern of
your world it's a way for the audience
to connect the dots and continue that
journey and that believability that they
are living in this or stepping into this
immersive world so it's a really great
way for you to look at the world that
you're creating whether it's in a video
game or a or an experience a physical
experience if you have someone walk in
and look at a place and in three seconds
if they don't tell you
exactly what you're trying to build then
you need to get back to work you need to
figure out a way that it can be because
our minds work so fast and we easily
break the world all the time
as visitors and participants to an
experience that you want to ensure that
you never give your audience member or
visitor an opportunity to break out of
your world and so
try the three second rule to create an
experience and a story that is truly
immersive so three seconds that's almost
like a couple blinks of an eye yeah yeah
that's how quickly you absorb the
environment that you're in I mean this
is a survival skill right that we as
human beings like we know that we're in
a safe place in a dangerous place is a
fight and flight response
um fight or flight and so for us to
quickly make sense of our environment
and our surroundings is something that
we as humans evolved to do so you know
in three seconds or less if you know
where you are and you can quickly make
sense of things then you feel safe
and when you have that safety then
you're willing to play then you're
willing to engage so you have to create
that safety net first and that's
something that is extremely important in
World building because if we really want
to take it back what is it Maslow's
hierarchy yeah the Maslow's hierarchy of
needs exactly so so security safety I'm
not sure where they fall on that scale
oh yeah that's the most basic thing
right that you feel um safe that your
life isn't threatened and then from
there you're able to enjoy the luxuries
and the pleasures of life so once you
create that safety net of knowing that
you know you're and that's why like when
you we create any type of immersive
experiences we always start with
um the uh the world the uh the rules or
the Rules of Engagement so you know you
say things like
um you know please ensure that you uh
you know whatever it is keep to the path
you know don't touch this or whatever so
that you have that sense of safety
before you enter the world and that's
one thing right to create those
parameters those safety guard rails if
you will the pool rules the swimming
pool rules and once you enter that
experience how do you create that next
step of once you've established that
safety that you can enter a place and
feel safe in those three seconds as well
you know
um and from there you know unless you
have you're building a horror house
which you don't want to feel safe right
you want to be terrified and scared and
running for your life but in any other
situation where you want people to play
and engage you have to ensure that they
feel safe first and foremost to interact
with others to play to engage to
discover to explore can they open
drawers
um but having that rule of the the three
second rule of looking around and
quickly figuring out okay this is a this
is a place that I can quickly
um you know in my mind know that I'm
gonna in this world I'm immersed in it
I'm safe to do the things that I'm
supposed to do is a really great way for
you to win your audience uh immediately
when they start the experience
in your book immersive storytelling I
think it was further in page 186 or so
you say as humans we need to have idle
time and occasionally be bored and
unproductive yes and I love hearing that
because I think a lot of times as
creative people we feel like I'm not
inspired today yeah there must be
something wrong like why why can't I do
something creative yeah
I believe in being bored and
unproductive wholeheartedly I think that
you know when we really think back to
um you know at least for me in my time
being a kid and not and feeling that
boredom and not having anything to do
um that's really when I you know pulled
out the blank sheet of paper when I took
my the felt and my scissors and glue and
started creating things and making
things
um and really trying to going learning
about that creative process and whether
it was good or bad it didn't matter I
just wanted to create and as you get
older you start you know editing
yourself and like judging yourself
before you even create the thing and
then you quit or you stop because it's
not great or you know you think that
someone else does it better or you know
all these things but I think that being
bored and unproductive
um is a great way to quiet your mind and
to reset and to shut out all the other
voices that's telling you what you
should be doing what you should be
creating and when you're bored and
unproductive
you'll be surprised to hear you know
your inner voice your inner artist about
uh and your inner creative about what's
meaningful to you you know when you stop
hearing other people's opinions and um
perspective on what you should be doing
in your in your life or what project you
should be working on next and all this
and I think that during the pandemic and
when we were isolating and in our homes
that was something that I experienced in
you know very
um uh in an
extreme form like all of us that we are
locked into our houses we couldn't do
anything about it we were bored our mind
out of our minds and we wanted to do
something again and for me personally it
felt like I needed to had have that
reset button to realize what is
important to me what's still important
to me what's no longer important to me
right and being
board and an unproductive helps you to
really have that open space in your mind
to accept what comes in
and
you'll be surprised you know you'll be
surprised by what does enter your mind
and your imagination when you're not
constantly inundated with noise and
chatter and uh distractions and so uh I
recommend everyone be bored and
unproductive at least one day out of the
week
that's a problem for some people because
over scheduling is its own form of
addiction yeah and so I think they feel
like I'm not being good if I don't have
like all these things that I have lined
up yeah like there's something wrong
with me oh yeah and it's a constant
struggle for me too you know because
especially uh you know living in La is
also I remember when I first moved to LA
people are like you know rushing from
one thing to the next and I remember
thinking oh I don't have that much to do
you know I actually have time to sit
around here for two hours and have lunch
but people were rushing from one thing
to the next and it affected me you know
over the years I'm like oh I have to be
busy too I have to be productive I have
to work on five to six projects at a
time like everyone else because that way
um that's how I would want the world to
perceive me as a very productive
creative or you know writer or artist
and after a while I realized well who am
I doing this for and you know if if it
is to please others then that is
definitely not my priority
um because life is short and we need to
do the the things that we ultimately are
meant to do in this world and in this
lifetime so being bored and unproductive
once in a while I'm not saying all the
time right because we all need to you
know do our things to earn money and you
know whatever it is we do
um but it's it's a really great reminder
at least to know that you don't always
have to be productive as
a human being as an individual that you
need time to rest you need time to uh
fill your well because that's something
that you know as a creative I
just need to walk around you know I need
to take a hike I need to do my yoga I
need to maybe walk around in a museum
without any goals at all and wander and
get lost and not have a destination and
maybe let someone else plan something
for me for a while you know and just let
go of all of those expectations
just for a while you know to have your
mind
refresh itself and to really
um you know think about what's
um you know what the most important
things to you will surprisingly come to
mind
um because you know oftentimes I think
we clutter our minds and our lives and
some people do that in you know in
manifests in actual things like when
they when people start cluttering their
houses and things like that right
um it's the same thing with our mind and
the more you let in
the more you perhaps start to lose what
makes you you and there's never going to
be another you in this lifetime or in
this you know in in the history of
humankind so uh why not why not just you
know let yourself
um
be unproductive not do anything so that
you can listen to your inner voice to
tell you what it is that you need to
do or not do I think it's a really great
way to gain perspective on your life and
it's something that you need to
occasionally do in your life